and the shortage of nurses around the
country continues to rise and with the
lack of staff hospitals calling on
travel nurses to help out madison
kimbrough spoke with umc's chief nursing
officer and madison is live with what
she had to say
the need for nurses in las vegas is
growing and here at umc they continue to
contract travel nurses in hopes that
they will decide to stay in the end
this whole phenomenon of traveling
nurses has really had an impact
in a lot of communities because the
rates that are being paid are just
skyrocketing we have situations where
nurses are making more money than
doctors that was patrick kelly of the
nevada hospital association during the
state covet update this week discussing
how travel nursing has become quite the
occupation as many staff nurses have
decided to pick up and leave to help
other hospitals in need at umc it's
vital they have a good amount of
traveling nurses on hand as deborah fox
their chief nursing officer explains we
actually got ahead of the coveted curve
i started recruiting for travel nurses
after the early first search we maintain
at any point in time around 88 to
120 travel nurses myra corona recently
made the move to being an icu travel
nurse after being a staff nurse in the
valley for years it's just ultimately a
jump that i had to take and like i said
i've my skill sets have grown
tremendously and it's helped me so much
as a as a registered nurse in general so
it's amazing and with the income myra is
making now there's no way she's looking
back the pay difference is
it's huge
i mean i can say in 13 weeks i make more
than i would have made as a in a whole
year as a staff nurse
and another reason why many switch to
travel nursing is due to flexible
schedules travel nurses are typically
contracted to work about 13 weeks with
the option of staying then they can go
to their next job or they can take a
break in between reporting live at umc
madison kimbrough live local now